A lion fell in love with a woodcutter's daughter...
...and told the man to let the girl marry him.
The woodcutter and his daughter were very afraid of the lion.
The woodcutter knew that if he did not let the lion marry his daughter,...
...the lion would get very angry and would kill, and eat them both.
The woodcutter knew that somehow, he had to find a way of killing the lion.
After a lot of thought, he said to the lion,...
..."I will be pleased for you to marry my daughter,...
...but she is very afraid of your teeth and claws."
"If you will let me take them all out, you can marry her."
"I am sure my daughter will then make you a good wife."
The lion could think only of how much he loved the girl...
...and wanted her for a wife.
So, he let the woodcutter take out all his teeth and claws.
As soon as the lion was toothless and clawless,...
...the woodcutter began hitting him with a heavy stick.
The lion could not defend himself without teeth or claws, so he ran away.
He was also unable to kill for food, so he soon died.